hello and welcome back today's video is
about drifters spoiler alert during the
battle of sekigahara toyohisa decides to
stay back so his uncle the commander of
the shimazu troops can escape in the
process doyohisa manages to mortally
injure the enemy general and likewise he
gets critically wounded but like the
ultimate badass he stands up and refuses
to die scaring the enemy army and
forcing them to retreat due to
doyohisa's perseverance and resilience
as he walks from the battlefield wounded
and bleeding toyo hisa finds himself
transported to a corridor of doors where
a bespectacled man at a desk waits for
him so the mad lad decides to do the
only thing he knows go and attack the
omnipotent man however he soon learns
monkeys can't bonk a supernatural being
as he gets sucked into one of the doors
and dropped into a field unconscious two
elven children find toyohisa and decide
to bring him to castle ruins the hideout
for two other drifters doyohisa's wounds
are stitched up and after waking up from
a dream he meets the demon king of the
six heavens oda nobunaga however he
doesn't believe that this is the real
nobunaga as the og was killed 18 years
before toyohisa's involvement in the
battle of sekigahara he also meets
yoichi a sassy looking archer who died
almost four centuries ago the trio
discusses how they met the same
eyeglasses rocking man who brought them
to the unknown world outside of their
hideout a busty spy monitors the
drifters she gets contacted by a man via
a magical crystal ball to check on her
status the man in white belongs to an
organization known as the octoberist he
wants to meet the drifters and orders
his men to get ready preparing for the
upcoming war with the ends and opposing
force advocating for the destruction of
the world in a desert wasteland hannibal
and scipio africanus are in the middle
of a heated argument while a member from
the octoberist organization observes
them from afar the observer gets ordered
by the man in white abe no semi to bring
the drifters to him in preparations for
the war against the ends meanwhile the
elven village located near toyohisa's
group of drifters is attacked and set on
fire by soldiers from the ortega empire
for associating with the drifters a
massive f up on their part as the main
man smells blood thusly sprinting to the
village to rescue the elves so he can
repay his debt to the young elves for
helping him earlier joined by nobunaga
and yoichi they easily defeat the
douchebags but it's not enough enraged
by the carnage and cruelty inflicted
upon the elves by the empire's soldiers
doyohisa brutally beats the commander
knight charged with massacring the elves
with the sheath of his sword before
convincing the elves to kill him
themselves back in the corridor of doors
the bespectacled man murasaki is visited
by his nemesis a goth chick named easy
who mocks his efforts to send drifters
to the unknown world to combat her ends
who have begun invading the southern
regions of the world now in the kingdom
of carneades seimei and his subordinate
tried to convince the commanders of the
defensive troops to let scifio and
hannibal take charge of their army
however the leaders refused to give the
two drifters command over their troops
seeing them as nothing more than useless
old men and that the fact that they want
to be in power a foolish decision
resulted in seymour withdrawing the
octobrus and the drifters from the
country as the ends in their army
consisting of dragons goblins and other
non-human races begin their attack now
from here on you need to focus lots of
name drops are coming your way the
leader of the ends the black end sends
hijikata jean d'arc and anastasia
romanova into the battlefield and
questions yoshitsune if his allegiance
is with the drifters or the ends a chad
yoshitsune vaguely states that he'll go
with the side that interests him the
most soon after a world war ii fighter
pilot now she descends into the world
and although he doesn't know what's
happening or where he's at now she
engages the black king's dragons thus
indicating himself as a drifter with the
aid of butch cassidy and the sundance
kid say make scipio and hannibal escape
from the city to join up with doyohisa's
group the black king orders the ends to
find the drifters and kill them
meanwhile the female spy monitoring
toyohisa's group is discovered by the
main man and his companions the spy
almenu informs the drifters that they've
been brought to the new world to fight
against the ends though the base trio
quickly rejects the idea much to her
shock big bubba explains to toyohisa
nobunaga and yohichi that their purpose
as drifters is to save the world from
being annihilated by the ends to
accomplish this she informs them that
the octobrists are tasked with gathering
the drifters together and appealing to
the kings and feudal lords of the
various states and countries to give
command over their armies to the
drifters however the demon king knows
better and he's certain that the lords
wouldn't allow outsiders to take charge
of their armies instead the gigachan
proposes that the drifters led by
toyohisa take over the ortei empire
scaring the buba on aldminu meanwhile
following his success at carneades the
black king tends to his wounded troops
and orders rasputin to spread the news
of the carniatus's defeat to recruit
more soldiers in their army back in the
elven village toyohisa's group offers to
assist the elves with their fight
against ortay to reclaim their state
though toyohisa and nobunaga fight over
the leadership arrangements as nobunaga
wants the mad lad to lead but toyo
doesn't want to they get interrupted by
the eldest son of the murdered
villager's chief who pleads for their
help doyohisa agrees to take the role of
the commander and begins to set a trap
for the orday forces to arrive in three
days on the third day a force of 200
authei troops marches into the village
only to find the uninhabited encamped in
the trees outside of the village the
drifters and elves prepared to strike
the orte soldiers at nightfall before
the ambush planned by the drifters
normunaga uses corpses and various
humans waste to create assault peter
pitt after toyohisa buries the heads of
the deceased as a sign of respect
meanwhile the elves begin training in
archery as night sinks in the auto
troops notice that the village's water
well was dumped with [ __ ] at nightfall
doyohisa and the elves launched their
attack on the old day soldiers as
nobunaga forms an enclosure to trap the
auto troops and continuously bombards
them with waste laid in arrows resulting
in wounds they can't clean since the
water is already filthy then doyohisa
enters the battle scene with a war cry
he beheads the commander of the troops
prompting the remaining soldiers to flee
in the forest yohichi kills the fleeing
soldiers who fall victim to excrement
infested traps after their successful
battle toyohisa urges the elves to
rescue the female elves disguised as
orte troops the drifters and elves make
their way to the local fort where the
main elf goes to kill an unarmed soldier
doyohisa stops him saying it's an
unhonorable to strike down an unarmed
man however when they locate the women
doyohisa discovers that the women have
been used as slaves by the old day
soldiers and just like that the honor
flies out of the window and all that's
left is rage as he vows to slaughter
them all in retribution after
successfully taking over the fortress
nobunaga rummages through the fort
office for vital documents at his
inquiry ominou reveals to nobunaga that
the founder of the orte empire was adolf
hitler who pulled a classic and
committed no breath shortly after
establishing the country 50 years ago
receiving word that toyohisa has lined
up the orte soldiers to be executed for
ripping the female elves nobunaga rushes
to the scene hitting him unconscious to
give the execution order himself so that
toyohisa doesn't have to dirty his hands
with blood in return after toyohisa
wakes up he punches nobunaga for his
interference and the two reach an
agreement to let doyohisa do whatever he
feels is right in the future then the
drifters return the women to their
respective villages with a proclamation
which contains information about the
heavy losses orte is suffering from
waging wars with numerous states as a
result elven villages across the land
begin to revolt and join the drifters in
autey's capital city the city's council
discusses the losing wars in neighboring
states particularly their war against
the merchant guild of gulbinin the drag
queen counseling jamie a powerful
nobleman and former ally to hitler
realizes orte's impending downfall and
chooses to seek an alliance with the
drifters at night four the chick with
anger issues jean de arc and her sim
gilderay as well as several soldiers of
the black king's army approached the
drifters hideout they arrive shortly at
the camp and the assault begins after
evacuating the elven women and children
toyohiza confronts jean who he mistakes
for a man while yoichi faces off against
the giant jill in the forest nobunaga
and the elves take care of the cavalry
with ominous assistance doyohisa was
able to defeat jean but refuses to kill
her when he realizes that the dude is a
chick meanwhile yuichi struggles in his
battle against sim frankenstein due to
the latter's inhuman strength and
durability before uh nearly killed butch
and the sundance kid arrived at the
scene using their gatling gun to destroy
jill's body and save uichi however
frankenstein is still standing with fire
in his heart that got extinguished when
he saw his tomboy queen jean being
rescued by the dragon riders thus he
dies with a smile and promises to wait
for jean to join him in the afterlife as
he disintegrates into salt after
reuniting with mrs bubba seimei
introduces himself to the drifters as
the leader of the octoberist
organization seimei skulls
for allowing jean to escape due to her
gender but he doesn't know he's talking
to the pride of the shimazu clan as toyo
he is determined to uphold his
principles and not become murasaki's
porn the next day comes and we see the
roman tactician scipio who was separated
from seymour's group during the ride to
rendezvous with toyo hisa's group he
encounters now she who's now been
appointed the sky god to a tribe of
anthropomorphic dogs back at the
drifters camp butch and sundance kid
explain the mechanics behind their
firearms to nobunaga who becomes
ecstatic at the notion of producing more
modern firearms and recalls how things
would have been if he had such weapons
under his disposal when he was alive
nobunaga reveals to a concern saying
that he wishes to create a multi-racial
federation with toyohesa as their leader
meaning he wants to unite the new world
at nightfall toyohisa leads his group to
free the dwarves from orte while seimei
butch and the sundance kid leave to
search for scipio and continue their
investigation on the ends while
counseling journey and his age journey
to the elven village to meet with the
drifters the ohisa's group attacked the
orte empire's largest armory in godolka
to save the dwarves utilizing the gun
powder the nobunaga has concocted with
the elves assistance the ohisa leads the
charge against a troop station there
however due to the heavily armed
soldiers they're unable to enter the
walled town after the orte soldiers
closed the entrance gate the one-eyed
tactician hannibal gives the one-eyed
demon lord nobunaga the idea to use
yoichi's arrows and alminus stone war
spells to cast a staircase alongside the
gate enabling toyohisa's group to invade
the town and free the dwarves so
toyohisa orders meals to be prepared for
them instead of taking down the castle
defenders though hisan negotiates with
the remaining orte troops to surrender
peacefully and allow them to escape
although he slays the commander when
yoichi prepares to pursue the fleeing
troops a habit he developed when serving
yoshitsune in the past toyohisa stops
him and tells him that he doesn't have
to follow dishonorable orders anymore
since this is their war much to the trap
boy's delight meanwhile a member of the
octoberist organization spy on the ends
at carniadis they're horrified to learn
that the black knight tore primitive
agriculture to the monsters that will
someday replace the humans once the ends
have eliminated mankind the black king
attempts to recruit one of the six great
dragons the bronze dragon into joining
his army but is met with contempt and
refusal by the latter for subjugating
his dragon brethren as pets in his army
using his ability to replicate the sales
of any life form the black king torches
the bronze dragon by causing his body to
suffer from cancerous growth to gain his
compliance yeah not very wholesome is it
afterwards rasputin presents the
completion of a simple alphabet and a
syncretic religion for the demi humans
to learn to help establish a unified
multicultural community as per the black
king's wishes meanwhile jean awakens
from her coma after her fight with toyo
hisa and is informed by anastasia that
has simp is dead and enraged jon vows to
avenge a fallen comrade by killing
toyohisa to which anastasia scolds jean
for her recklessness before promising to
her to do as she pleases when the time
comes back in godolka nobunaga requests
that the dwarves begin forging muskets
for their army to use in future battles
the next day khao san jamie and his
fellow queens arrive in godolka to meet
with the drifters sending his aides to
test toyohiza to see if they're worthy
to ally with sanjimi reveals to big
bubba that he's a drifter and that he
wants to sell the orte empire to the
drifters before orte is destroyed by
other warring countries to accomplish
this sanjimi recommends that the
drifters overthrow the orte empire and
seize their territory
while san gimi's aides sneak the
drifters in their army into the orte
empire's capital city sanjimi holds an
emergency council meeting with the lords
charged with overseeing orte and informs
them that he's selling the country to
the drifters his attempt to coerce the
nobleman to surrender peacefully however
is disrupted by rasputin who possesses
two of the nobles to reveal that the
black king is also planning to seize the
orte empire for his campaign however his
actions are proven useless in the face
of absolute aggression as lord toyo
hissan proceeds to kick a noble man's
brain out and after being humiliated by
toyohisa and nobunaga rasputin retreats
and the black king sends hijikata and
his troops to combat the drifters in the
capital shifting their focus from
seizing orte to destroying it to prevent
the drifters from obtaining it to assist
with the ensuing battle sanjimi gives
his army back to the battlefield where
nobunaga is commanding the army's gunner
squad while toyo hisa and yoichi lead
the dwarves and elves respectively into
the fray after the drifters successfully
out maneuver and outplay the ends
vanguard angering hijikata and making
him join the battlefield as the drifters
and their army decimate the ends troops
hitikata gives orders for his soldiers
to break into smaller units and disperse
into the streets setting the city ablaze
while heading to autodesk's capital
buildings hitikata and toyohisa meet in
the street to fist it out although
hitikata was using the ghostly images of
dead shin sengumi to attack toyohisa
meanwhile nobunaga and hannibal decide
that instead of chasing the ends troops
they'll trap their enemies in the
capital buildings when they arrive and
kill them with yoichi's squad and
alminus reluctant assistance with the
army destroyed the black king orders
hijikata who was getting his ass clapped
to withdraw from his fight against
toyohisa back in canaadis rasputin
apologizes to the black king for their
failure in seizing orte although the
black king is pleased that they're able
to [ __ ] the capital city and gauge
the drifters strength and the show ends
on a cliffhanger when we find out that
our getty has joined the black king and
ends lines after hearing nobunaga's
voice during his encounter with rasputin
so this is it for today's video if you
liked the video give it a huge thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel for more
videos farewell till next time